We're on problem 28.
Four pumps begin draining
a 5,400 gallon pool.
At the same time, two pumps
begin draining a
4,000 gallon pool.
Assuming that all of the pumps
drain at the same rate, how
many gallons are left in the
smaller pool-- so the 4,000
gallon pool-- when the
larger pool is
finished being drained.
And notice they didn't tell us
how fast the pumps work, so
let's just assume that.
Let's say that each
pump drains at
x gallons per minute.
So four pumps will drain at 4x
gallons per minute, two pumps
will drain at 2x gallons
a minute.
So how many minutes does
it take to drain the
5,400 gallon pool?
Well, it will be 5,400 gallons--
I'll just write g's,
or I'll just say gallons--
divided by x gallons, or
actually 4x because we
have four pumps,
4x gallons per minute.
And what is this equal to?
If we divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2--
actually, let's just
divide by 4.
4 goes into 5,400, 4 goes into
5 one time, 1 times 4 is 4,
bring down the 1.
4 goes into 14 three times.
3 times 4 is 12.
20, 4 goes into 20 5 times.
So it goes 1,350 times.
So this is equal to 1,350 over
x minutes to drain the 5,400
gallon pool.
Now, how much has drained out
of the 4,000 gallon pool at
that point?
Well, we're going
to be draining
2x gallons per minute.
And how long are we going
to be doing that for?
Well we're going to do it
until-- or we're going to be
watching this experiment-- until
this pool is completely
drained and we've figured out
this is how long it takes to
drain it: 1,350 over
x minutes.
So, if we're going to be pumping
out at 2x gallons per
minute, in the smaller pool,
because we have two pumps, so
2x gallons per minute, times
this many minutes, times 1,350
over x minutes.
This is going to tell us how
many gallons have pumped out
of the 4,000 gallon pool.
So the x's cancel out-- you have
an x in the numerator, an
x in the denominator.
The minutes cancel out, so our
answer will be in gallons.
So it's 2 times 1,350.
So what do we get?
We get 2,700 gallons.
That's how much has been pumped
out of the 4,000 gallon
pool, right?
This is how much has
been pumped out.
2x times 1,350 over
x is 2,700.
That's how much has been pumped
out, but they're asking
us, how many gallons are left
in the smaller pool?
So if we started with 4,000, and
we subtract 2,700, that's
going to be 1,300 gallons
are left in the pool.
That is choice A.
Problem 29.
Use the graph below to answer
the question that follows.
Switch colors, ease
the monotony.
The graph above shows the
distance, d, in miles, and the
time, t, in minutes for six
bus routes around a city.
Which of the following equations
best models a
relationship between d and
t for these bus routes?
So these are different
bus routes.
It's almost a line.
I mean we can kind of-- let me
do it in a light color so I
don't mess up the graph-- but we
can see, you know, I see a
line that looks something like
that, right there, if I had to
fit a line into there.
Let's see, which of the
following equations best
models the relationship?
So t is equal to d, what
would that look like?
That line-- I'll do it in this
light green color-- t is equal
to d, so when t is equal to
10, d is equal to 10.
When t is equal to 20, d is
equal to 20. t is equal to 30,
d is equal to 30.
So that's this line
right here.
That doesn't seem to model these
black dots too well, so
it's not going to
be that answer.
Let me do another one.
t is equal to d plus 10.
So if we start at 10, so
when d is 0, t will
be 10, right there.
When d is 10, d will be 20,
right? d plus 10, 20.
When d is 20, t will be 30.
It's going to look like this.
This is a little, it's an
improvement, but it still
doesn't look that great to me.
So, let's just, yeah, it's
probably not that.
t is equal to 2d.
Well, 2d, when you're
0, you're at 0.
When t is equal to 10, you're
going to be at 20.
When t is equal to 20, you're
going to be at 40, so it's
going to go like, something
like this.
It's going to look something--
40 right here-- it's going to
look something like this.
Which is close.
It seems to have the
right slope.
Let's look at the last choice.
I'm guessing the last
choice is going to
get us right there.
t is equal to 2d plus 10.
Let me do this in blue, because
I have a feeling this
is the right answer.
So we start at 10 when
d is 0, t is 10.
And then we go up by 2d.
Or another you can think of
it, when d is 10, we get 2
times 10 plus 10.
We're going to go to 30.
When d is 20, 2 times
20 plus 10 is 50.
We're going to be at 50.
So the line looks something
like this.
It will look like that,
which is a pretty
good fit of the curve.
It's definitely the best out
of the four choices.
So I'll go with D.
Next question.
Let's see.
Are there any questions
on this page?
No.
Next page.
Next question.
Let's see.
Use the graph below to answer
the question that follows.
OK, they've drawn us
a little line.
They've drawn some points
on the line.
The graph above represents the
equation wx plus 4y is equal
to minus 12.
What is the value of w?
So they're esentially, they gave
us two points, so we can
easily figure out, actually,
the equation of this line.
Maybe we do not have
to go that far.
So if we can just write this
line, y is equal to mx plus b
form, and maybe if we just
figure out the slope of the
line, that'll be enough.
So they said that the line
is wx plus 4y is
equal to minus 12.
If we subtract-- I just want to
put it into the standard mx
plus b form.
So if we subtract wx from both
sides, we get 4y is equal to
minus wx minus 12, and then
divide both sides by 4, you
get y is equal to minus
w over 4x minus 3.
So this is the equation of the
line, and we have to figure
out what w is.
This right here, minus w over
4 is the slope of the line.
So let's figure out
what the slope is.
Slope is just change in x.
Slope is equal to change in x,
over-- sorry-- is equal to
change in y, change in
y over change in x.
Rise over run.
How much do you change in y
when you change a certain
amount in x?
So in this case, it's going to
be equal to-- let's take this
as our first point.
So we take the y's.
2 minus minus 3 over-- right,
that's the change in y-- 2
minus minus 3, right?
And then, the second one, we use
the 2 as the first point
here, so I use the minus 4
as the first point to the
denomintor.
Minus 4 minus this
x value, is 0.
So the slope here is equal
to 2 minus minus 3.
That's the same thing as
2 plus 3, which is just
5 over minus 4.
So this is the slope.
So 5 over minus 4 has to
be the same thing as
minus w over 4.
You could write minus 5/4 is
equal to minus w over 4.
You could pattern match
that immediately.
The w has got to
be equal to 5.
You could also solve for
w, but let's just
do the pattern matching.
That makes it easier.